let's go next to
um let's go to jack from minnesota jack
welcome
hey david um how are you doing i'm doing
well
uh so
i've been kind of wondering this all my
my entire political uh
you know since i've gotten into politics
uh
how genuine are some of the the people
on the right because you have people
like ben shapiro who's harvard grad uh
etc etc he should know that he is lying
to his audiences uh you know every day
or
or is there a possibility that he just
believes the things he believes in
well i think it depends on which issue i
mean i think that there's probably
some areas where there's a genuine
belief in some areas where there's like
a knowing exaggeration i think it's an
issue by issue thing
okay per yeah
um
because i've just been wondering because
i'm i i just genuinely don't know if
there's method in the madness of
of some of these people
yeah it's you know i think it's for me
it's more interesting rather than the
media people it's more interesting like
when when you see interviews at a trump
rally
and the people just parrot all the same
stuff that these people say like oh the
election was stolen and the raid was
illegal and benghazi and hillary and
obama gay and all this stuff like do
they remember do they even know that
they're being
you know grifted and lied to or are they
genuine believers that's a more
difficult question to answer to me and
also a more interesting one
okay yeah it is um
i guess that's all thank you for taking
my call all right thanks jack jack from
minnesota with a beautiful question